[Music]
gasps sir I play Hymie
hello everybody this is the bedbugs
episode I've just been in a shower with
all my clothes on but your baby
[Music]
directing Hannibal Arturo and Abby to me
if I'm not in the scene it's so much fun
and it's it's like it's just play it's
just so fun and play but being in the
scene I felt very self-conscious because
you can't even filter your thoughts
you're like or I felt like I was like
totally dude okay I'm just totally dude
okay now know when you like turn to me
it's like it just like you seem like a
crazy person
great smaller maybe we got them from
Abby don't you yeah I do this this is
the first season I think you see them
actually getting an argument over the
bedbugs that was like an overnight and
just him and me scene after scene after
scene and I went nuts I was like a
maniacal monster but it was so right
that's really exciting because even when
they're fighting they're still fighting
is like really like family you know what
I mean let's we mentioned having that
you gotta slap in the face I might have
gone too far
broad city was my first big gig you know
and after that other stuff has come but
like I haven't found a sense of family
or a sense of belonging like I do here
you know I mean I don't know man I feel
like the luckiest man in the world
[Music]